you are bright you're killing it um
you're going to be presenting something
right yes yes yes laura spencer smith
okay yeah one of the singers
yeah
one of the talent here at window tango
yeah who are you listening to right now
who's on your summer playlist
definitely shawn mendes yeah definitely
camila cabello
um
and i love latin music man because i
mean that's the music i dance to right
so yeah anything latin anything salsa
yeah
deer got engaged congratulations to
daryl no i can't finally derek no
kidding
it's about time
what was your reaction is that what you
said to him that's what i said to myself
finally derek no i said congratulations
i mean this is it's amazing they love
you he's so in love i've known derek
since he was 10 years old so um yeah
it's been a long time coming and i'm
happy that he finally put a ring on it
yeah yeah i've always just loved how
open and honest you are and you're
you're very like sharing especially like
with the podcast and things like that um
why is that so important to you because
i know you're going through it right now
so i want to know
how how and why you know i i been
blessed i guess to be able to tell my
story and my experience and i've um
since i started my youtube channel it's
been i know it's helped a lot of people
you know i know a lot of people can
relate to the everyday stuff that we go
through and just because i'm on
television doesn't mean i'm not a human
being and you know we all go through it
and it's also selfishly in a way it's
healing for me and my soul
and i also love to hear from people and
it's been a blessing in disguise whether
it's because of my therapy or whatever
but to be able to open up like that just
so people know that they're not alone is
my goal so oh i love that yeah that's
really sweet cheryl oh my god okay
um okay that just threw me off okay a
performance is there one person in
particular that you are just so excited
to see or is there anyone that you would
fangirl over at this point i mean
honestly sean mendes oh yeah fan girl is
that a love vibe or is that
i am newly divorced this is so fresh is
there a phone call we can make i'm not
even ready to date this is what burke in
the game my podcast is all about is
getting me into date shape
i like oh i like it great because i've
been out of the game for a long time so
yeah okay okay well i'm not looking but
hey chamen doesn't sing me a song or two
if he wants okay yeah next wango tango
we'll check this time next year i'm
kidding we're gonna have a conversation
for me actually oh i should look that up
i doubt it but we're looking up so he's
up he's legal eight i'm kidding
thank you you're so sweet thank you
you